have confirmed chip Chapman of the Mayor
of London Rudy Khan speaking has not
been declared as a terrorist incident
I'm in close contact with senior
officers here at New Scotland Yard and
I've been fully kept updated with events
and I've been kept updated this
afternoon it has been confirmed that a
number of people were injured in the
attack some seriously my heart goes out
to them their families and all those
affected as soon as it's possible to
provide an update on their condition the
Met Police will do so I'll ask you to
please respect the privacy of those
affected emergency service responders
attended the scene including officers
from the city of London and Metropolitan
Police a male suspect was shot by
specialist armed officers from the City
of London police and died at the scene I
want to thank our brave emergency
services who responded to today's
horrific attack every day they put their
lives on the line for us running towards
danger in order to keep us safe I would
like to thank members of the public who
risked their own safety this afternoon
they are the best of us terrorism is
cowardly and evil we must and we will
stand united and resolute in the face of
terror those who seek to attack us and
divide us will never succeed I'd ask all
Londoners to remain vigilant and report
anything suspicious to the police I'd
like to take some questions
years ago do you know anything more
about the role of that vehicle well I've
been kept updated all afternoon but I
think it's important for this isn't
Commission Neel Basu to ask specific
questions about bats and the
investigation it's really important the
police have the time to count
investigations they will answer
questions and do cause
well first we can't say anybody who's
got images of this afternoon either port
on their phone or other devices please
share that with the police there is a
website set up we can share those images
it's very important you do so also not
just to respect the identity of the
armed officers and please don't put in
the public domain their identity but
also what's remark about the images
we've seen is the breathtaking heroism
of members of the public who literally
ran towards danger don't know in what
confronted them we do know from the
statement given by the Assistant
Commissioner nil Basu that there appears
to have been a device on the suspect
members of the public didn't realize at
the time that was a hoax device and they
really are the best of us another
example of the bravery and heroism of
ordinary Londoners running towards
danger risking their own personal safety
to try and save others that always say
thank you to them on behalf all
Londoners but also because it shows the
best of us
I'm mayor of the greatest city in the
world one of our strengths is our
diversity but we do know there are
people out there who hate our diversity
who hate what we stand for and I trying
to seek to divide us what was amazing
about today is we saw in the one
individual the suspect the worst of
humanity but we also saw in the response
for members of the public but also
emergency services the very best of
humanity and the message on a send
register Londoners not just through the
visits to our city but around the world
is we are resolute we stand united in
the face of terrorism and will not allow
anybody to divide us
well I know speaking to colleagues
around the world mayors of other great
cities that were all targets for
terrorists the factories since the four
terrorist incidents in 2017 because of
the excellent work of the police and the
security services and because of the
intelligence provided members of the
public we flirted more than 20 attempts
at terrorism on innocent citizens and
what some really important important is
that we all remain vigilant if anybody
sees anything suspicious please report
it to the police
or on the side of caution I'd rather
people over report to the police and the
experts than under reports but it's also
really important we are the police to
current investigations it also asked
them is the press to please respect the
privacy of all those who have been
injured today and their families as well
well we know that a couple of weeks ago
the threat levels were reduced from
severe to substantial we also know one
of the things that terrorists tried to
do to disrupt our way of life and stop
us going around going about our normal
business today's a day when many of our
shops will be extremely busy and we know
and unfortunately because of this
terrorist attack travel has been
disrupted in London London Bridge the
trains and the troops still not stopping
London Bridge and many of the buses have
been diverted the advice from the police
and the count's terror experts is this
appears to be an isolated incident the
police are looking for anybody else if
that changes of course the police would
let people know but I'd remind members
of the public that we've been here
before in previous decades our city has
been under attack from terrorists one of
the things we've always been successful
at doing is standing resolute and not
allowing terrorists to disrupt our way
of life but simply and get about
business as we approach Christmas but
also not allowing anybody to divide our
communities it's really important that
we as Londoners stand shoulder to
shoulder with one another for stand
resolute in the face of a terrorist or
an individual or others to see to divide
us always review threat levels it's a
regular thing they review colleagues
will be aware it was it was reviewed
recently and reduced from severe to
substantial jtech of others will
constantly keep these things under
review and it's really important that we
recognize that this was one individual
and that there was huge bravery from
members of the public as well as the
first responders but at this time my
thoughts and prayers are with all those
injured and those affected by the into
this afternoon thank you all very much
you